[Music]
hello and welcome to a new start a new
chapter
in my literary career such as it is the
launch of my newest book into the
impossible think like a nobel prize
winner
these are lessons from laureates to
stoke curiosity
to spur collaboration and to ignite
imagination in your life in your career
and i never thought i'd write a
self-help book but serious scientist
writes a self-help book i guess maybe
i'm not a serious scientist
but this book was simply a book i could
not not write and that's really the
criterion the rubric that i use to
decide if i'm worthy of writing a book
am i the right person to tell this story
and actually in this book i'm not
telling the story very much it's really
the nine nobel prize winners who've been
featured so far on into the impossible
more to come
and i decided i could not
ignore their wisdom i wanted to
as you know in my life my goal is to
convert knowledge to wisdom they're not
the same thing
and to me to take the lessons from these
magnificent individuals and turn them
into life lessons that you can apply if
you're an aspiring theoretical physicist
or the proverbial you know car sales
woman in omaha nebraska
you are my avatar i want to show you the
commonality between what you may be
doing and what these nine magnificent
minds have been doing
and also to confront the
biases the prejudices the limiting
beliefs that we all have most notably
the imposter syndrome which most if not
all of the laureates
in this book grapple with on a daily
basis even after winning the nobel prize
and so i hope you'll enjoy this book
it's been endorsed by the likes of